hello I'm not John John punishment was
do five videos in five days but
unfortunately it looks like he's not
going to do that because of something
something I'm not gonna tell you about
right now I don't know if you know this
but I actually have a version of
question Tuesday's as well it's when I
answer one of your questions in a very
long-winded fashion and then I ask you
like twelve questions it's a
little-known because we've never
actually done it but that's what I do
instead of question Tuesdays so I'm
gonna start with the most frequently
asked question I receive dude how many
chocolate favorite espresso beans did
you eat today that's probably the
question I get the most often the answer
to that question and every single all of
my videos has been none in fact I pretty
really just leave on caffeine because as
you can imagine the effects on a guy
like me might be a little bit dangerous
but in order to show you what that's
like I have here a shot of espresso with
some milk and some water and some sugar
which is how I like it I love the taste
coffee I just don't like caffeine and
I'm gonna drink it and you're gonna see
what happens
I'll just take four caffeine hit on
Google about five minutes with the peak
effects at thirty minutes so I should be
doing a tune I have not yet started to
feel the effects of the coffee maybe I
have instead like like a little brick
wrap the meantime let's talk about wine
John's not here unfortunately John has
spent most of the day in the doggie
hospital oh not the doggie hospital
Willie is okay don't worry but Willie is
also um adorably injured this is
probably the most adorable broken foot
that you've ever seen here it is oh my
god so that's why John's excused because
his puppy has a peg leg just a question
of John can you get an eye patch and
maybe a parrot an eye patch at the very
least for tomorrow's video I want to see
an eye patch in addition to the peg leg
because while you know I'm definitely on
Team Ninja a pirate that would be pretty
awesome
toast Oh cute yeah that's cute but but
give it a peg leg yeah yeah now on
eyepatch yes
so while we're waiting for the caffeine
to effect now comes apart the video wow
the caffeine has taken effect now comes
word to me or I ask you questions okay
okay resisting urge to buck like a
chicken
so since Michigan I've been having this
problem I can't stop thinking about the
difference between mono and uni there
Latin prefixes for the same thing why
aren't there just mono Versa T's and
mono tardes
no he's monotonous no you not miss
nobody ever dies of carbon
dioxide poisoning
another thing with Latin why is trivia
trivia that's like three streets three
street pursuit also been wondering if
they're more murders on TV or in real
life of anybody could let me know
excluding wars are there more murders on
TV or in real life I don't want to vote
look at chicken win win win I went like
I go through airport security and I like
forget my change that I put in a little
thingy what happened to that did the
people is take it or like does it go to
the US Treasury four times I've gone
through and like left you know 35 cents
and you know I was on a big deal for me
but I don't know what happened that
money maybe there should be I think
there should be AI think there should be
a tip jar for transportation security
people because that job sucks don't
wanna bark like a chicken hmm can you do
anagrams and math if anybody knows any
way to incorporate anagrams into math I
would really like to know about that one
of those evil people have pets like this
the head will have a pet they're like
Stalin have you know about evil people's
pets let me know huh do you want to copy
of Paper Towns because in this video I
actually get to give one away this is
the first time I've got to give it away
so I give it away button lucky write
them come to receive on Oh Stewie
what the Frick is up with an iota what
is an iota why is there only one why can
you never have to I Otis I don't care
one iota does that mean if you have
answers to any questions at all
including the ones that I just asked
that also including all the questions in
the world leave them in the comments I
appreciate it thank you
I'm John I'll see you tomorrow